beau on sait pas bonjour c'est parce
qu'à ce jour à tous merci au capitaine
du nexus 6 d'être avec nous mais je suis
ravi martin je t'en prie je connais les
concepts oui les projets tout regret
c'est vrai depuis depuis j'attends
d'être invités ok alors quiz
est-ce que cher capitaine
il ya des gens qui ne connaissent pas
encore le nexus 6 tu peux nous dire
vitesse que c'est alors en exercice est
une chaîne spécialisée dans la science
fiction c'est mon vaisseau spatial donc
sur le capitaine d'équipage en fait
l'idée c'est de parler d'oeuvre ou de
sujets de science fiction tout ce qui
est science fiction discipline entendez
et en même temps vous avez sur nos
aventures dans la galaxie
moi j'ai le 23ème siècle là j'ai fait
l'effort de me déplacer dans le temps et
dans l'espace et le temps de la facture
et voilà je vous invite si vous aimez la
science fiction ou pas d'ailleurs
allez jeter un coup d'oeil aux abonnés -
toute équité dans une complète de tous
genres c'est la critique de film mais on
peut s'achever c'est scénarisé htc dans
un univers tout ça et je trouve qu'il ya
une vraie plus value c'est tout ça cool
il permet un produit gens pas du mieux
dans le dernier t'imagines si avec
viviane ça sur une question qui était
t'imagines si on pouvait se cloner donc
dès maintenant et vous avez mis plein de
commentaires et on va les lire avec le
capitaine pas de générique maritime pas
encore de gérer que mais sa rivale à
tout le monde aura en clown dans une
clinique en prévision d'un accident ou
d'une maladie pourquoi regrettez vous
transporter son souci de compatibilité
et de disponibilité et ce dans le cas où
les clones sont maintenus en vie
activité et croissance artificielle
eh bien oui sûrement je pense bah en
fait est ce qu'ils seront en entier ou
est-ce qu'on va pas clos
que certaines parties ouais parce que
moi je pense que déjà son à des
problèmes de rythme et de place de
ressources et c'est un machin six pompes
plus ont été clonés
déjà je pense qu'il serait que les plus
riches bah voilà c'est ce que j'allais
dire c'est que ce problème de place il
va être ça sera certainement très cher
ou bien voilà il en est archi passion
c'est à dire des personnes - moyens ils
feront clos n'est qu'un hacker une
partie tu verras s'est exaucé des
options de voiture c'est ça d'après ce
qu'on adore ce juste mon torse c'est non
mais par contre est ce qu'il ya un
intérêt en fait qu'ils sont pas tous ces
clones et juste des partis bien que
vraiment d'intérêt en fait un clone et
tout le corps lorsque je lance ma place
et on dit je pense qu'en plus si on
clown tout le corps je n'étais pas là du
tout de suite à quel âge on a besoin
aussi de la chose ce que je comprends du
commentaire ces lieux en gros on clown
ton corps en même temps que toi ta
naissance ou quoi et on le fait évoluer
artificiellement en même temps que toi
en parallèle est comme ça quand un
emplacement organes après ça marche
moyen parce que sont le corps est
passionant influée par l'environnement
dans lequel ils évoluent si le corps il
ya allongée et qui se déplace pas les
muscles ne développe pas au clavecin
d'utiliser en fait exact exact mais du
coup aux actes
j'aime à penser ça du coup bah ya dans
le film thaïlande je vois très bien plus
j'adore ben voilà en fait ils font
croire aux clones que ils font partie
d'une société dans laquelle il faut
atteindre un idéal ça en gros ils sont
sélectionnés pour aller vivre dans un
paradis
sauf que spoiler en fait c'est faux
quand ils atteignent ce paradis en fait
tu oublies tu pour récupérer les organes
pour lui donner à une personne riche
dont ils sont les clones
donc ça ce serait logique mais ça pose
la question du chômage et n'obéit
éthique ça que pose la question éthique
de le faire évoluer directement pour
pouvoir prendre ses organes active
qu'ils aient conscience mais il avait
oublié ex mars politiquement très désolé
c'est la vie dégoûté fait c'est juste
cette recherche de mentalité oui mais
par emplacement et doit justement ou
alors autant tu peux remplacer le club
n'a fait que remplacer le cerveau par
des ondées partie de ton cerveau parler
d'un par exemple sais pas où tu me up du
couple ce gars là
il remplace par le cas mais le cerveau
une fonction retenir les ouvriers à
macha ce serait plutôt un même à force
de remplacement en fait tuer alors ça
c'est ma licence et ben c'est un gros
gros débat clos ce film est un exemple
est le bateau de taizé sétois jeu j'en
ai entendu parler
en gros c'est
c'est un bateau c'est un exemple
philosophique on roule pour un bateau
est pas pour changer les voiles ensuite
tu vas changer amour d'une époque
ensuite tout
et si bien que la manche suivante de
pièces d'autos
[Musique]
ça en fait c'est le cas nous notre camp
se nourrit cherche à tâtons constitue
elle même salué la naissance tous les
cinq à sept ans certains nouvellement
total de toutes les cellules donc je
parlerai à dire qu'au bout de cinq ans
si on pouvait se cloner bon je te serai
tous du 60
je continue mon choix serait toutefois
s'en sort et jongler on aurait tous un
gros nez rouge à aaa
c'était poupe poil bravo non mais ça va
on dit là il abritait il aller loin si
l'on pouvait se cloner alors toutes les
lois sur les droits de l'homme seraient
changés peut-être que nos clown
deviendrai les gens esclaves
de plus je pense qu'ils soient dans
l'incapacité de se reproduire les
cloneurs évitant tout problème génétique
aussi jury et ça rejoint ce que tu
disais tout à l'heure sur le sec en gros
les clones seraient des citoyens de
seconde alors c'est un choix de société
c'est très certainement au bout d'un
temps une certaine rébellion
ça c'est le genre de merde ça crée des
révolutions il faut apprendre de
l'histoire aussi quand tu crées des
citoyennes second tome ya un moment dans
la vie ils vont se rebeller
ça c'est vraiment pas une bonne idée où
il y aurait des gens qui se battent qui
serait colonies ce genre pas mal de
clubs rey a dans ce sens cela va
certainement je pense certainement irin
série space 2063 tout le monde a oublié
dans lesquels il ya une partie des
humains qui ont été créées in vitro
c'est pas des clones chez deux humains
créant finalement il faut maintenant et
ça a été des citoyens de seconde zone
c'est marrant ils ont leur nombril dans
le coup
parce que dans la cub c'est la tâche et
c'est comme ça qu'ils le reconnaissent
ses synthèses mais là ce qui est
intéressant dans cette question c'est
l'aspect enfin disent les clones
n'aurait pas le droit d'avoir un enfant
oui pourrait pas se reproduire
et ça c'est vrai que ça pourrait poser
foot à merde citons clown à l'enfant qui
c'est pour toi jeune et oui voilà si ton
clown il a un enfant l'enfant
il est pas clown et tu vois des hilal
est censé avoir le même droit que
citoyens de première zone
m même ça pourrait être un enfant en
fait oui oui j'ai publiquement sa clé
dans le cas où par exemple une femme qui
est stérile parce qu'elle est un
accident tenu des russes dommage que son
clone elle puisse avoir un enfant à sa
place
mais l'autre effectivement l'enfant même
l'enfant en fait un clone serait
juridiquement ton enfant voilà l'enfant
un peu en fait n'est pas et n'a pas le
statut claude c'est pas sa faute
ça peut être une décision due au monde
après celui qui n'est pas content
l'original jean noël augert ce serait
une décision d'origine elle ou
d'original ne pas porter l'enfant mais
maintenant même en imaginant un couple
de claude clandestins ouais ils ont fui
et décide à voir la l'original qui
serait furax
mais voilà déjà cet enfant qui naît de
cette île dont les taux c'est un
original
en fait oui oui mais les originales des
originaux devient le nouveau mot bombe
ce qui pourrait se plaindre parce que le
clown à la décision de se reproduire
avec clown qu'il n'avait pas décidé
parce que peut-être que 2 original pour
décider d'avoir un enfant ensemble mais
via leur chloé un enfant avec un autre
clone du coup pas dû à ça ferait trop
basse et indécis même si perdre aux 13
autres testons cyrus franchement très
bonne question
c'est au bout et ce clown et sans
échanges équivalent alors on aurait une
quantité influent de bouffe à
disposition de même pour tous et dire
qu'un texte n'est pas encore en maître
pensons-nous et de sensibilité et ses
avants 150 alors abattre immédiatement
de clonage dans le but d'avoir sauf
qu'on peut alors imaginer que certaines
personnes qui feraient de la bonne
viande auront un intérêt privilégié ça
peut penser un petit peu à l'expulsion
population il n'y a pas besoin de faire
les clowns puisqu'on est déjà bien assez
sur cette voie là il ya bien assez de
voir tous les jours pour nourrir la
savait qu'elle était juste devant button
claude n'avait pu le tuer alors on voit
aujourd'hui que les gens qui ne mangent
pas d'animaux lors de la phase aller
bouffer wicklow navré pense pas
quant à éliminer toutes les ressources
de la planète le capitaine vous savez ce
qui est vrai cependant sur les animaux
la technologie sera sûrement utiliser
pour une production de clients
importants en évitant une prime de 120
même utiliser pour leurs populations
d'espèces entrée en bonus track
une énorme évolution on était les spas
aujourd'hui on ne donnerait pas des
animaux crée déjà le port d'extinction
par exemple mais par contre devront
utiliser conapo espèce en voie de
disparition
maintenant il reste plus que deux
rhinocéros finances locales au niveau
pool génétique c'est pas fameux quatuor
m'inscris pas fameux on aura des
bizarres que deux cordes
après on est tous apparus à partir d'une
cellule quoi donc
allez allez c'est pas je connais pas
votre truc
bref capitaine est-ce que vous avez
passé un très bon très très bon moment
merci normal ça fait longtemps longtemps
pour les prévu on est honnête par les
buttes en forme avec ce machin
nos chemins se sont rencontrés mais ça
viendra
moi je te remercie mais alors comment
j'espère pour le ps parce que temporaire
en général je sais moi qui me déplace je
te tabasse et je t'enlève je t'emmène au
20e siècle
c'est souvent ça mes collaborations vous
irez voir souvent je te tabasse les gens
bon bah tu penseras j'ai à dire merci
beaucoup merci à tous les gens qui m'ont
aidé contestée du père intéressant ici
le nom est gagnée même boîte meilleur
jeu du monde plus racing magix
voilà comme ça la prochaine question ce
sera celle là la question de la
prochaine fois c'est imagine si les
animaux pouvaient parler
donc je vous laisse balancer vos
réponses en commentaire et on va lire
tout ça la prochaine fois avec tanguy de
la chaîne tout pète
merci normalité n'hésitez pas à les
check et la chaîne lexus is qui ne parle
pas que de smartphones google
j'essaie de sérieux mais ceci oui des
grenats à papa c'est le hockey c'est à
très bientôt love is now
[Musique]